hi I'm Andrea Gibson and this is my poem
the nutritionist the nutritionist said I
should eat root vegetables said if I
could get down 13 turnips a day I would
be grounded rooted so my head would not
keep flying away to where the darkness
lives the psychic told me my heart
carries too much weight said the $20
she'd tell me what to do I handed the 20
she said stop worrying darling you will
find a good man soon the first
psychotherapist said I should spend 3
hours a day sitting in a dark closet
with my eyes closed and my ears plugged
I tried it once but couldn't stop
thinking about how gay it was to be
sitting in the closet the yogi told me
to stretch everything but the truth said
a focus on the out-breath said everyone
finds happiness if they can care more
about what they give than what they get
the pharmacist said : open lamictal
lithium xanax the doctor said an
anti-psychotic might help me forget what
the trauma said the trauma said don't
write this poem nobody wants to hear you
cry about the grief inside your bones
but my bones said Tyler Clemente dove
into the Hudson River convinced he was
entirely alone my bones said write the
poem to the lamplight considering the
riverbed did the chandelier of your
faith hanging by a threat to every day
you cannot get out of bed to the
bullseye of your wrist to anyone who has
ever wanted to die I have been told
sometimes the most healing thing we can
do is remind ourselves over and over and
over other people feel this to the
tomorrow that has come and gone and it
has not gotten better when you were half
finished writing that letter to your
mother this is I swear to God I tried
but when I thought I'd hit bottom it
started hitting back there is no bruise
like the bruise loneliness kicks in to
the spine so let me tell you I know
there are days when it looks like the
whole world is dancing in the streets
will you break down like the doors of
their looted buildings you are not alone
and wondering who will be convicted of
the crime of insisting you keep loading
your grief into the chamber of your
shame you are not weak just because your
heart feels so heavy I have never met a
heavy heart that was in a phone booth
with a red cape inside
some people will never understand the
kind of superpower it takes for some
people to just walk outside somedays I
know my smile looks like a gutter on a
falling house but my hands are always
holding tight to the ripcord of a
leaving a life can be rich like the soil
make food of decay turned wound into
highway pick me up in a truck with that
bumper sticker that says it is no
measure of good health to be well
adjusted to a sick society
I have never trusted anyone with the
pulled back bow of my spine the way I
trust the ones who come undone at the
throat screaming for their pulse to find
the fight two pound four nights before
Tyler Clemente jumped from the George
Washington Bridge I was sitting in the
hotel room in my own town calculating
exactly what I had to swallow to keep a
bottle of sleeping pills down what I
know about living is the pain is never
just ours every time I hurt another
wound is an echo so I keep listening for
the moment when the grief becomes a
window when I can see what I couldn't
see before to the glass of my most
battered dream I watched a dandy line
lose its mind in the wind and when it
did it scattered a thousand see so the
next time I tell you how easily I come
out of my skin don't try to put me back
in just say here we are together at the
window aching for it to all get better
but knowing there is a chance our hearts
may have only just skin their knees know
there is a chance the worst day might
still be coming let me say right now for
the record I'm still gonna be here
asking this world to dance even if it
keeps stepping on my holy feet you you
stay here with me okay you stay here
with me
raising your byte against the bitter
dark your bright longing your brilliant
fists of lost friends if the only thing
we have to gain and
staying is each other my god that is
plenty my god that is enough my god that
is so so much the light to give each of
us at each other's backs whispering over
and over and over live live live for an
interview with the poet watch this video
or check out the next poem in this
series
[Music]